what is going on everybody and welcome
to a reinforcement learning tutorial
series in this video we're going to be
starting off with cue learning now every
time I do a new series people are like
what are the prerequisites really for
any of the series there aren't any just
anytime we hit a concept or topic you
don't understand look it up in this case
though there really shouldn't be
anything if you know basic Python you
should be able to follow along with the
cue learning tutorials pretty well now
when we start getting into deep cue
learning that changes now you need to
note ends are flowing chaos and stuff so
so just keep that in mind but at least a
start pretty much anybody should be able
to follow along here so first of all
what actually is cue learning the idea
of cue learning is to have these like
cue values for every action you could
possibly take given a state okay and
over time we want to be able to update
those cue values in such a way that
running through a chain of actions will
produce a good result okay now that's
done by rewarding some sort of agent as
they get through this environment and
the idea is to kind of reward for the
long term goal rather than in any
immediate short-term actions now cue
learning specifically is what's called
model free learning the idea is that the
the key learning model that we rewrite
basically the cue learning algorithm is
applicable to like any environment it's
not really environment specific so the
code that we write should be mostly
applicable to any other environment that
we might want to use it in as long as
that environments simple enough so cue
learning in the way that you know what
we're about to work with is is good for
really basic environments but it's not
going to do anything really complicated
for that you're gonna have to start
getting into deep cue learning or
something like that so anyways I think
the best way to learn is by doing so
let's jump in so we're going to need a
couple of things right out of the gate
so go ahead and pip install Jim
I should already have it and then also
go ahead and pip install if you can type
on like me install Matt lib grab that as
well we're gonna be using that in a
series and I might forget to tell you to
get it but it should be it so so I'm
gonna go ahead and go into Q learning
here and just edit this file should be
empty for now don't need that right now
cool so the first thing we're gonna do
is just kind of poke around get an idea
for this environment so even though it
doesn't this environment like doesn't
matter much to our AI it matters to you
to understand how Q learning actually
works so what I'm gonna go ahead and do
is fix this first of all there we go
import import Jim and then what we're
gonna say is the environment is a Jim
not make and the environment we're gonna
use here is mountain car dash of v-0 and
that's title cased mountain color
anytime you have an environment the
first thing we're gonna do is reset and
then we are ready to actually iterate
through this environment so what we're
gonna say is done equals false and then
while not done we want to step through
this environment now to do a step we
need an action so for now I'm going to
say action equals two now again for your
benefit I think it's useful to
understand how the environment works but
in terms of your agent
it doesn't need to actually know but for
your own information Mountain car this
environment has three actions that you
can take now in a little bit I'll show
you you can actually pull all of these
Jim environments to figure out how many
actions are there but in this case just
for simplicity sake I'm just gonna tell
you there's three actions and actions
zero is like push this car left action
one is do nothing action two is push the
cart right so I'm just gonna say
basically push the car right is our
action and we're just going to do that
every time so we're gonna say m dot step
we're gonna say action and then m dot
render and
fact I think I'll already populate this
that way we don't have to worry well
we'll hit an error if I don't do this so
the next thing we're gonna say is new
underscore states comma reward comma
done comma underscore equals m dot step
action so every time we step with an
action we get a new state from the
environment so this date is the things
that were like sensing from the
environment basically in this case the
state has two values its position and
velocity but again like I can I'm gonna
continue repeating your model it doesn't
really matter all that much what these
values actually are as long as they're
meaningful obviously we don't want
meaningless data here but to the
environment our to the agent it really
doesn't matter but just for your own
curiosity's sake the values that we are
getting from here are position and
velocity of this car and Vautrin der so
that'll show it and then if done is done
great and then if we are done we're
gonna do an end 'don't close
I'm gonna save that I'm gonna run it
from a terminal length on cue learn one
PI and we should get great so as you can
see this car is trying to get up this
mountain for this hill I'm not sure I'd
call that a mountain but hmm anyway it
just clearly doesn't quite have the
horsepower and instead what it needs to
do is build momentum by going up here
swinging down here and then building up
and and the goal is to eventually make
it to this yellow flag area so okay so
how do we do that it's actually really
really simple we just we just do this
duh-huh me obviously so um so this is
the actual function here for calculating
these Q values but don't worry you don't
actually need to know how to read that
or write from it we're gonna convert
that to Python in due time but basically
the way that this is gonna work is we
want to create this this cue table it's
this large table that given any
combination of states we can just look
it up on the table right so given any
combination of state of position and
velocity for every combination of
position and velocity we just want to
look up on this table hey what is what
what are the three in this case Q values
at this position and velocity and as
long as we're trying to exploit the
environment we're just gonna pick the
one with the maximum the largest Q value
that said when we initialize this Q
table we just initialize with random
values which also means those values are
random and useless so so actually
initially our agent is going to do it we
call explore a lot which means do random
stuff and then slowly update those Q
values as time goes on so anyway that's
a lot of information to throw at you so
so I think the first thing we're going
to do is build the Q table and then go
from there so so first of all let me
just print will print new state save
that did I actually I think I closed the
console Q learn I'm just gonna run it
again and we're just printing out now
the states so as you can see here we've
got all these states being printed out
now this is the first issue that we're
gonna come across with Q learning and
that is that these values like that's
out to what is that eight decimal places
that's a lot of decimal places can you
imagine every combination of these two
values out to eight decimal places
that's a lot so that would make for a
huge table that's just gonna blow out
our memory not only is it going to blow
out our memory but the amount of time
it's gonna take to learn on a table of
that size in the amount of episodes we'd
have to like run through to do so I mean
by time we were done quantum computing
would be like a huge thing already so so
we don't want to wait that long so now
what we need to do is is convert these
continuous values to what or referred to
as discrete values basically we want to
bucket this
information into buckets of some sort of
size now what size those buckets are is
it's going to be a yet another one of
many variables that we're gonna set and
likely need to tweak as time goes on so
so with that let's go ahead and get
started here so first of all and so
basically at this point we can start
pulling some information from this
environment one of the things that we
can do is print n dot observation
underscore space dot hi and then let's
just print the low real quick low and
then one of the other things that we can
print is because I just I just want to
point this out I think we'll end up
using it anyways but it's yeah it's
action underscore space dot in and
that'll tell us how many actions we can
actually take so say if we'll just run
that in here so as you can see this is
the high value for all of the actions or
I'm sorry all of the observations
possible now another thing to note is
you might actually have reinforcement
learning engaging in some sort of
environment where you actually don't
know these values and you actually might
just engage in this environment randomly
for awhile before you even start to
learn these values so in this case it
the environment is gracious enough to us
to report these values but we might
actually not know and then here with
actions chances are you'll know your
actions in advance no matter no matter
what I can think of a few use cases for
like reinforcement learning at least
where you wouldn't but pry not queue
learning but anyway we can pull the
environment of any of these gym
environments this way to know exactly
how many actions are possible ok so the
next thing that we want to do is create
we want to figure out how we're going to
create this cue table so so we want this
Q table to be of a size that's at least
manageable so how we're going to make
that size I'm just going to say
discretes observation observation space
or OS size and in this case we're gonna
say 2020 now I'm gonna change this in
just a second I am kind of on the fence
as far as like hard coding this I think
that a real or reinforcement learning
agent would not have this hard-coded
because it would change by environment
but you won't necessarily always want
these values to be the same number like
this one maybe you want 50 and then this
one should be 20 and so on but for now
what I'm gonna say is just going to be
20 times the Len of any observation
space things so I'm just gonna pick one
at random so this is 2 so it's just 20
times 2 so it's a 20 by 20 ok
I'm only doing that just because I
really want this code to be at least
functional on every environment possible
so I just don't want to hard code that
because some environments will only have
to observation values they might have 5
10 100 who hopefully not but maybe so
anyway cool so alright so we've got the
discrete observation space size so with
that entire range so from 0.6 to
negative 1.2 we want to separate that
range into 20 chunks or 20 buckets or 20
discrete values okay however you want to
call it that's what we want to do and
then we want to do the same thing for
the range of 0.072 negative zero point
zero seven we want twenty chunks and
buckets that way we don't just have this
infinitely continuous range that would
be forever for us to learn so now we
need to know how big is that range how
big are those chunks
you know like each step through those
chunks how big is that number so now
we're gonna say discrete OS when size is
equal to n
really are you not gonna help me
observation space dot hi
I was really hoping it would just like
autocomplete that entire thing for me
yeah anyway - MDOT observations spaced
out low and then I'll add the spaces
around that I'm pretty sure that would
be Pep eight then what we want to say is
/ discrete OS size that's freaking huge
and then what I'm gonna do is I'm just
gonna print this out just so you can see
what I'm talking about so now print not
in all caps though print discrete OS
winds sighs we'll run that real quickly
and you can see now you okay so so for
positions each bucket will be of a range
that is 0.09 long and then over here
0.007 long for the velocity chunks and
knowing that I would say I'm just gonna
guess that's probably granular enough
and in fact I'm not guessing already
know it's gonna work so so it will be
but sometimes you might find that you
have to tweak these values and again
like I said sometimes they won't
necessarily be the same between two so I
just I made this change because I want
it to work across all environments and
by work I mean just the code should run
but really you would take your
q-learning scripts and make them far
more dynamic and probably also run like
a few maybe even a few hundred episodes
to tweak these numbers a bit but because
this is not our stopping point I'm not
gonna spend a bunch of time doing that
like we're gonna get into deep Q
learning and stuff so I don't I don't
want to spend too much time there we
will spend a little bit of time talking
about how we can optimize these numbers
but yeah anyways moving on so discrete
win size is now known so finally we can
create the cue table so again I'm gonna
open up paint because paint is love and
paint his life
the objective at the end of the day for
us is to have this like massive cue
table okay
and so I'm just gonna draw just the best
table you've probably ever seen in your
life and as you've seen we have 33
actions right you've got action zero
action one in action two right and then
over here you've got every possible
combination of well now it's only twenty
by twenty so it's a much smaller set of
you know it's only four hundred things
right but you know this would be I don't
know combination one combination two
combination three and then we're
wherever the agent finds itself whatever
combination of position and velocity
that it finds itself in it's going to
come to this table and it's going to see
what are the Q values for this specific
combination so for action to maybe it's
like a zero it's a two and A one okay
and these are the Q values so then it's
gonna look what is the highest Q value
well it's a two so it's gonna perform
action number one because it number one
has the largest Q value so over time at
least initially the agent is going to do
a lot of exploration so it's just gonna
pick a random value but then over time
as it picks these things and eventually
reaches a reward then using the Q
function for this lovely thing that
we'll probably talk about in the next
video it will slowly kind of back
propagate that reward to make for higher
Q values for the actions that when
chained together lead to that lovely
reward but for now we need to rent we
just need to initialize this Q table so
later we can update this Q table so the
way that we're going to initialize this
Q table is we're going to say Q on our
score table
is equal to oops NP dot random dot
uniform and then we're gonna say lo
equals and we're gonna start at negative
two hi equals zero and again these are
two variables that you're gonna want to
probably tinker with given different
environments
and and that's why in one of the
subsequent tutorials we will have to
talk about like how do you analyze these
environments because it's not you know
there's no tensor board to pull up and
check the loss you know so anyway these
the the the intuition behind why these
should work is the rewards that we're
going to be getting basically when we
print we even printed it out here
oh no we only printed out the new state
since it's since it's part of what I'm
trying to yak about right now let's just
I'm gonna comment that out and I'm gonna
print reward and then new State so now
you can see all of the rewards I'll do
that in the console so coming over here
we didn't see that the reward here is
always a negative one and again to your
agent it doesn't really matter all that
much but to you it might and that so
basically it's good the reward is gonna
be a negative one until you were you
reach that flag at which point your
reward will be zero so so yeah so so
that's how once it finally reaches that
flag it's zero reward which is higher
than negative one I guess I think we
should get a bigger better reward
personally but once it reaches that flag
and then we back propagate those that
chain of events basically so anyways we
can see here that the rewards are always
negative one until a good thing happens
so we can initialize the table into the
negatives because we're pretty confident
that that's where like the values will
eventually lie at about negative one or
maybe not negative one but in the
negatives for sure so so it just kind of
makes sense intuitively to start it
there but again you'd want to be
probably tinker with a lot of starting
values to be honest and then given
enough time it should figure it out
anyways but anyway coming back to our
cue table so our low is going to be
negative two our high is going to be
zero and then finally our size is going
to be equal to
the discrete OS size which if we come
over here that's a 20 by 20 so the table
is 20 by 20 so when we do make a 20 by
20 table of this discrete observation
space size that contains every
combination of observations that we
might find so every combination of
position and velocity then we need
values for every single action that's
possible so the way that we're gonna do
that is discrete observation space size
plus m dot oops m dot action space dot n
so this should make us a 20 by 20 by
three so it's a three dimensional table
but basically you can just think of it
as its every combination of possible
environment observations times three
actions that we could take and then
inside of those cells or whatever you
want to call on you're gonna have your
three at this point random Q values
between negative two and zero
but over time through this agents
exploration and exploitation those
values should get slowly tweaked and
optimized based on that but don't worry
we'll write that in Python and it makes
so much more sense at least to me and
Python than it does in that stupid
formula but for now let me go ahead and
just print a cute table dot shape and
let's make sure it's what we expected NP
is not defined let's go ahead and import
import numpy as NP we'll try one more
time 20 by 20 by 3 and then if you
wanted to look at it you could but we're
not really gonna do anything from it
it's not going to look very meaningful
to us just understand it's every you
know possible observation combination
and then the Q values for at every
possible observation combination and
every combination of or every possible
action at every possible combination we
have a random starting Q value
you okay so I think I'm gonna cut it
here and in the next video we will talk
about how to actually start training
this model iterating and going over
these the steps per episode and all the
episodes and all that so with that a
shout out to my longest term channel
members these are people who have been
with me for a year or more
that's incredible I can't believe it's
been a year that I've had these but
Stannis Coe or stenosis Coe my longest
term member thank you very much you're
an awesome human being
miss NJ are Magali and wheatgrass thank
you all so much for your long-term
support you guys are awesome and you're
not just supporting me you're supporting
the free education for people who may
not be able to afford it otherwise so
that's really cool you guys are amazing
people thank you so much for your
support if you guys want to support the
channel you can click on that blue join
button I know some people don't have
access to it for some reason but if you
have it and you want to support the
channel you can click on that right
there otherwise if you've got questions
comments whatever about q-learning
please ask them below I can't tell you
how many cute learning tutorials I ended
up having to go through before slowly
figuring it out and I just can't I hope
that my tutorial will be more useful
than all the other ones that I found
myself on so so if your find yourself
lost or confused please ask definitely
want to help you understand q-learning
I think it's pretty cool so anyway in
the next video we will hopefully finish
up our agent actually have it
driving on to that flag every single
time anyway I will see you guys in that
video